thomas
à chaque instant dans chacun de vos
gestes
à chacune de vos respiration ou de vos
battements de coeur vous êtes en contact
avec des énergies invisibles et pourtant
bien présente les quatre éléments la
terre l'eau le feu et l'air tout ce qui
existe sur cette planète de vivant
chaque organisme vivant en est constitué
et ils sont présents en cet instant même
en vous est parmi nous toutes les
grandes traditions qui existent sont
intéressés au sujet entre l'aïe ojeda
des hindous ou la médecine
traditionnelle chinoise où les chamans
les alchimistes les poètes aristote
pythagore hippocrate
même le père de la médecine parler de la
médecine des quatre éléments pour
expliquer le fonctionnement du vivant et
tous s'accordaient à dire que pour
expliquer comment fonctionne le vivant
et comment fonctionnent les quatre
éléments il y avait un principe de base
c'est l' équilibre quand un organisme
un corps est en souffrance c'est parce
que justement il ya un des quatre ou
plusieurs des éléments qui est en
déséquilibre
je ne suis pas médecin je ne suis pas
chaman ni alchimiste
mon job c'est justement d'accompagner
les individus les organisations les
entreprises a justement retrouver
l'équilibré
dans ce monde en changement est en fait
j'ai découvert qu'il y avait une
corrélation assez étonnante entre le
justement l' équilibre des quatre
éléments
dans un organisme vivant et cet
équilibre aussi qu'on peut retrouver
dans les organisations
alors comment ça m'est venu je suis né
en bretagne près des marais salants où
il ya cette alchimie entre le soleil
la mère mon père était maître du feu au
fond des cales des bateaux des chantiers
navals à saint nazaire
mon grand père était agriculteur il m'a
appris la magie de la nature et des
saisons
un jour j'avais 7 ans il m'a tendu une
baguette de coudrier une baguette de
sourcier si vous préférez et il m'a dit
trouve moi l'eau dans le jardin et sur
mon air un peu interpellé il précise
connecte à l'eau en toi et tu connectera
l'eau de la source est en effet avec ma
baguette très rapidement sans poser de
questions j'ai trouvé rigoureusement
tous les endroits dans le sol on pouvait
trouver de l'eau et donc creuser un
puits j'étais en contact
invisible avec l'eau alors c'est vrai
que ça faisait un peu partie du folklore
familial entre mon grand père un peu
droid sur les bords ma tante qui passait
le feu quand on était brûlée ou le
rebouteux du village ça fait partie de
mon quotidien c'était normal pour moi
mais j'étais quand même très jeune déjà
en contact avec les quatre éléments
mais fallait quand même passer aux
choses sérieuses les études
alors pour moi ça a été les langues
je suis monté à paris commerce
international
je me suis même préparé pour les
concours d'entrée du quai d'orsay
je voulais devenir diplomate je voulais
amener la paix dans le monde rien que ça
alors ça c'est pas vraiment passé comme
je l'avais pensé
j'ai d'abord commencé par faire de
l'intelligence économique consultant
j'ai parcouru une partie du monde pour
me retrouver à new york pour une très
grosse multinationale française
alors là je peux vous dire que les
éléments et tous m'ont folklore breton
était déjà bien loin
et pourtant un jour de septembre 2001
j'avais un magnifique appart à manhattan
j'avais des amis
j'avais un job qui me plaisait j'étais
amoureux et en face de moi j'ai vu
tomber deux tours et au même moment j'ai
vu déferler une vague sur la ville de
pleurs de tristesse d'émotion et au même
instant dans la même magnitude une
énergie opposé la haine la colère le feu
le feu de la guerre à la télévision et
dans les yeux des gens que je croisais
et là j'ai compris que les éléments qui
constituaient notre monde était
justement en plein déséquilibres alors
j'avais pas et diplômes pour ramener la
paix dans le monde mais je venais de
l'intéressé un sujet qui était le
développement durable la responsabilité
sociale et environnementale dans les
entreprises ça commençait à me
passionner et je me suis dit qu'à mon
niveau j'allais contribuer dans un
endroit que je né sais très bien quelles
sont les entreprises et j'avais envie de
contribuer à ce que ces organisations
redevienne plus responsable plus
conscientes de leur impact sur la nature
sur la société plus transparente plus
éthique plus humaine et si c'était
possible en tout cas j'avais envie à mon
niveau à mon échelle de faire ma part
alors je rentre à paris et depuis quinze
ans je fais de l'accompagnement au
changement je passe mon temps à
accompagner les individus les
organisations les entreprises alors
donné des idées des outils de l'énergie
pour se préparer au changement
à ce nouveau monde qui vient mais un
constat s'impose la nature c'est le
changement mais la nature humaine elle
elle déteste le changement qu'est ce qui
se passe quand on apporte le changement
dans une organisation dans un collectif
est quelque chose qui serait j-10 fille
qui se pétrifie même alors que justement
il devrait devenir plus souple quand on
apporte le changement justement ont
débordé motion la peur de changer le
deuil de l'ancien et l'information ne
circule plus alors que justement on
devrait retrouver cette fluidité dans
les échanges
qu'est ce qui se passe quand juste
parfois on apporte juste une idée comme
ça
parfois il ya des gens pour qui ça
réveille lanville envie d'agir l'envi de
contribuer l'envi de créer et puis pour
d'autres je vois dans leurs yeux la
haine la colère l'envié de me voir
disparaître tellement je suis en train
d'amener la révolution dans leurs
boutiques
et puis parfois ce que je constate par
du temps c'est que les organisations ou
les entreprises
elle manque juste tout simplement
d'inspiration et là en fait mais eurêka
j'ai compris depuis 15 ans j'avais
devant moi les éléments il était
toujours présent et donc en effet comme
le disent tous les alchimistes où les
médecins il est absolument nécessaire
dans une organisation comme dans un
organisme vivant de maintenir ces quatre
éléments
les fondations la raison d'être
la terre la communication les échanges
loue la créativité l'envi l'entousiasme
la passion même le feu et l'inspiration
ou la vision l'air sauf que le monde
qu'on traverse actuellement il est
complètement bouleversée changement de
modèle économique
changement de système éducatif
révolution politique
changement de nos modes de communication
tout change tous les éléments sont
bouleversés et partout dans toutes nos
serres de vie pas juste au boulot dans
nos communautés dans nos familles dans
nos couples en nous aussi quand on
traverse une période difficile
quand justement on doit le vivre ce
changement qu'est ce qui se passe on a
toujours tendance à pousser le feu a
résisté et qu'est ce qui se passe que ce
soit individuellement ou dans
l'organisation on peut faire un burn-out
avec ce feu le burn out mais maintenant
dans notre lexique on en parle déjà des
éléments et qu'est ce qui se passe quand
il ya le feu
il faut de l'eau justement il faut
remettre des échanges de la fluidité de
l'accueil de l'empathie pour pouvoir
apaiser ce feu est parfois justement
quand on manque d'idées dans vie parfois
il faut savoir prendre l'air retrouvez
d'autres idées et justement grâce à ses
idées nouvelles
il ya le feu qui peut renaître un peu
comme quand on souffle sur des braises
et le feu peut repartir
le feu de cette énergie créatrice et
parfois quand il ya trop d'émotion quand
justement l'eau ne circulent plus que
l'eau stagne on imagine une flaque d'eau
juste en dessous ça pourrit la structure
ça pourrit la terre est sacré les
ambiance pourrie au boulot ou à la
maison
et parfois quand on est beau mais quand
on est déraciné suffirait juste de
s'inspirer un peu comme ce proverbe
africain
tu sais pas où tu vas regarde d'où tu
viens sans dessein moment là où
justement il faut revenir à nos racines
pour pouvoir à nouveau retrouvé notre
axe créateurs et donc c'est cet
équilibre qui nous est intéressant
d'observer quelles sont
ces éléments en trop ou en insuffisance
dans nos vies dans nos organisations
dont on a besoin de retrouver confiance
pour retrouver l'équilibré en ce monde
en changement
en fait ce que je vais vous avouer c'est
que j'en ai marre du changement parce
que si on veut arriver à contribuer à
quelque chose de plus grand que nous à
cette transformation que l'on veut pour
ce monde il va falloir passer par
quelque chose de plus puissant et au
delà des quatre éléments
ça suffira pas de jouer avec les quatre
éléments la terre l'eau le feu et l'air
va nous falloir passer par un autre
élément plus important un peu comme ma
main ici il ya quelque chose qui le
pousse qui est le doigt le plus puissant
m
qui peut tenir n'importe quel autre doit
un peu comme cet élément qui peut
soutenir n'importe quel autre élément
est ensemble tout transformer ce
cinquième élément
c'est l'esprit c'est la conscience c'est
l'âme c'est l'amour c'est comme vous
voulez je vais appeler ça l'esprit et
l'esprit on en parle tout le temps même
dans nos organisations
pensons à l'esprit de l'air ce monde des
idées
rappelez-vous tous ces grands créateurs
tous ces grands génies ceux qui ont
bouleversé et transformé à jamais notre
quotidien tous ces grands esprits
justement archimède léonard de vinci
nikola tesla beethoven bach tous étaient
dans des états d'esprit particulier
quand ils ont atteint cette fulgurance
cette intuition forte et qui leur ont
permis d'avoir cette idée magique
révolutionnaire qui nous impacte encore
aujourd'hui penser à newton
il était en train de faire sa sieste
dans un état d'esprit particulier quand
il a reçu cette pomme sur sa tête et
qu'il a compris l'attraction terrestre
et cet esprit du feu un autre
révolutionnaire génie contemporain steve
jobs
il a été viré sa propre entreprise à
l'âge de 30 ans et ça a été la période
la plus créative de toute sa vie
justement il a pris un moment pour se
recentrer connecter à son intuition et
c'est à ce moment là qu'il a imaginé
next qui a ensuite complètement
révolutionné apple qui l'a imaginé les
studios pixar et qu'il a reconnectés à
ce feu sacré à cette passion et qu'il
revenait aux affaires chez apple et qui
les a transformés cette entreprise et
qu'il en a proposé des produits
absolument révolutionnaire qui
continuent encore à impacter notre
quotidien maintenant et l'esprit de
l'eau penser une équipe de rugby
chaque joueur pris individuellement
sister strictement à rien ce qui est
important pour chacun cette entrée en
contact en empathie en connexion fluide
permanente en écoute solidaire et c'est
par cet esprit d équipe que peut-être on
peut réussir à gagner un match
vous vous souvenez cette équipe de
bobsleigh jamaïcaine lors des jeux
olympiques à calgary
rasta rocket
il leur en fallait un sacré esprit
d'équipé pour arriver à tenir jusqu'au
bout et traversé la ligne d'arrivée et
l'esprit de la terre c'est cette
puissance énorme ce sentiment d'être
ensemble et data d'appartenir un
collectif cet esprit de corps nécessaire
à tout collectif rappelez-vous au delà
de la colère ou de l'émotion
l'état d'esprit dans lequel vous étiez
le 11 janvier
l'année dernière le 13 novembre
l'esprit charlie souvenez-vous de ce
moment de communion d'humanité d'unités
vécu ensemble
c'est donc bien par l'esprit qu'on va
réussir à transformer ce monde
en fait au-delà des quatre éléments
il sera important d'intégrer ce 5e qui
est indissociable des autres il est tout
le temps présent
il est à votre service c'est vous les
alchimistes c'est vous les médecins ça
dépendra en fait de votre état d'esprit
de votre bon goût de votre mauvais
esprit que vous pourrez contribuer à
transformer ce monde est en fait il ya
une dernière chose que nous partager
depuis longtemps les alchimistes les
grands penseurs c'est que notre état
d'esprit si on veut l'élargir si on veut
élargir notre conscience c'est pas ici
que ça va se passer
la fois l'art qu'on descende de 40 tout
petits centimètres et qu'on s'installe
ici et que coeur à coeur en contact avec
la nature on puisse imaginer les
solutions
dont on a besoin durables celle-ci
et c'est ici en s'installant ici qu'on
va pouvoir réparer nos collectifs abîmée
c'est ici à se tendre la queue dans nos
organisations on va pouvoir mettre du
coeur à l'ouvragé et peut-être faire que
ce monde retourne à nouveau dans le bon
sens merci